Now, I don't want to spend a ton of time on
this, but it is newsworthy in a sense.
So I want to take a look at it with you.
I told you previously about Donald Trump's
niece, Mary Trump, who wrote a book with a
ton of outrageous but not altogether surprising
claims about Trump.
He has a learning disability.
He paid someone to take his essay tease.
He was abused by his dad.
He was taught never to apologize because his
dad never apologized.
And they were all believable, but also not
ground shaking claims in the sense that they
don't really change our picture of who Donald
Trump is.
Well, Mary, Trump's book is out and it's sold
just a crazy number of copies on day one.
It was close to a million copies sold.
And Mary Trump was interviewed by Rachel Maddow
on MSNBC.
And Mary Trump says she personally heard Donald
Trump use the N-word, referring to black people
and also anti-Semitic slurs.
Let's take a look.
Have to press you on it a little bit.
Just to ask if the president if your uncle
was an exception to that in your family or
if he if he if if you hurt, you ever heard
him express either his anti-Semitic slurs
or the N-word or other racial slurs or other
sentiments like that?
Was was it?
Do you mean this is an ambient thing in your
family, but you can't say that you ever heard
it from him or did you hear it from him, too?
Oh, yes, of course I did.
And I, I don't think that should surprise
anybody, given how very lightly racist he
is today.
Have you heard?
Have you heard the president use the N-word?
And anti-Semitic slurs specifically.
Yes.
So this is one of those that it's so obvious
and yet so irrelevant and yet so seemingly
confusing in some minor ways, which I'm going
to explain.
So one of the reactions from the right and
I looked at some conservative blogs and sub
credits this morning to see their reaction
to this.
A lot of people on the right have said Trump's
not anti.
He's super pro-Israel and his daughter converted
to Judaism because she marriage Mary Jared
Kushner, who's Jewish, etc..
The terrible argument, because, first of all,
Trump is pro Israel from a reactionary Netanyahu
sort of standpoint, which is not even the
predominant view among Jews there, nor here
in the United States.
So Trump really has done nothing about Jews
being increasingly the victims of hate crimes
during his presidency.
He moved the U.S. embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem.
Right.
So understand that Trump has been prolly cooed.
But Trump has not been pro Jewish.
And that's an important distinction to make.
Number two is this is just not surprising,
right?
From everything we know about Trump, who can.
Oh, my God, it's shocking.
Trump uses the N-word in private.
Should Trump uses anti-Semitic?
Of course he does.
That's not at all surprising.
But then the most important takeaway for me
is as sick as this is, it's so relevant in
the sense that Trump is so orders of magnitude
unqualified to do this job.
Trump has so bungled everything that he deserves
to be removed in November.
Period.
And this barely changes anything about it.
OK.
You know, I get it.
In so far as Trump using the N-word personally
hasn't gotten very much attention.
Trump using anti-Semitic slurs.
Personally, it's not getting that much attention.
I get it.
You know, when Mary Trump said this on The
Rachel Maddow Show, it got 24 hours of attention
and then it faded.
There's two reasons for that.
The corona virus pandemic continues to rage
and grow.
It's not surprising that Trump is accused
of saying this.
But most importantly, it's not materially,
materially relevant to voting Trump out.
It changes nothing if you still support Trump
at this point.
You're probably not bailing because he's accused
of using the N-word about black people and
using anti-Semitic slurs about Jews.
You're just sticking with him.
If you're still with him at this point, if
you're already not supporting Donald Trump,
you're still not going to support him after
hearing him accused of using the N-word and
anti-Semitic slurs.
In other words, it is additional data that
provides almost no additional information
about who we should vote for because it's
what we believed he was doing all along.
That's my two cents on it.
Let me know if you disagree or have something
to add.
We probably won't spend much additional time
on it.